welcome to data science tutorial
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
that is w www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead what's in it for
you today
we're going to cover what is data
science
need for data science data science life
cycle
data science components data science
applications and a hands-on demo in
python
so what is data science data science is
the field of study that deals with
modern
scientific techniques statistical
methods
and algorithms to derive insights from
vast volumes of data
companies using data science are very
numerous
with companies generating data every
minute
there is a need to make sense of this
data
mu sigma fractal fidelity intel
jim pact cubela amazon trindins
connect the dots just about every
business out there
nowadays uses some form of data science
even if it's indirectly to help govern
their business
and help them growth and compete in the
business world and we use the data
science to find
unseen patterns within the data analyze
and draw insights from our data
and solve business problems and make
decisions
and the data science has a life cycle
we start with our data discovery then we
go through data preparation
exploratory data analysis data modeling
interpret the results and back to data
discovery
we talk about data discovery data
discovery involves asking the right
questions identifying the business
problems
finding the best solution and gathering
correct data from relevant sources for
analysis
this is in the data science life cycle
the most important step
now in general it only involves like a
small percentage of the time you spend
on this
but if you're not asking the right
questions you can't go in the right
direction
data preparation data preparation deals
with cleaning the data
finding the inconsistencies tackling
missing values converting it into the
right format and making it ready for
analysis
when i'm running the data science life
cycle this is probably where the most
time
is spent data can be so
messy you have to break it down into
different parts you have to import the
different pieces from different
databases
are you dealing with straight numbers
off of spreadsheets and cells
or are you dealing with text documents
and natural tokenite language
tokenization exploratory data analysis
analyze and visualize the data using
different charts and graphs to find
significant patterns and hidden trends
that helps to understand the data better
the building of the charts
is very creative probably one of the
more enjoyable parts is be able to come
in there and describe the data
and show that to the shareholders then
we dive into data modeling
use classification regression and
clustering algorithms to build machine
learning models
that can help predict and forecast
future trends
this is where we start getting into
predictions
what's next where's it going to go and
then interpret the results
validate the model results draw the
final conclusion and check if the
performance of the model is in line
with the requirements the final step is
the one that you set up in front of the
board members and give them suggestions
as to what's next where we're going to
spend our marketing money
where are we going to start preparing
our fire fires for the next fire breaks
next year
what is the weather patterns coming in
this is where you interpret the results
and say how accurate they are
are they valid is it something we're
going to keep are we going to throw it
out and have to start over
we look at data science components
there's the mathematics
statistics domain expertise
data engineering data visualization
and machine learning when we sum this up
in data science
really this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain
expertise now when you're taking your
classes obviously you want to go through
the mathematics the statistics the data
engineering the data visualization the
machine learning learning all those
tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools
then you're able to ask the right
questions and deal with it
when we talk about the tools in data
science and where they sit
there is a data analysis data analysis
focuses more on statistics and
mathematics
where the data science size where the
data science side
focuses more on the machine learning
data visualization
and then there's database management
which really focuses on the data
engineering part of it and how to manage
that data in the data flow
and you see all these components come
together and then they form the data
science
and we talk about tools in data science
we have
sas we have matlab we have sql
you have your apache spark your r table
python right now in the programming
languages
python is probably the most widely used
with
r coming in a close second the reason
for that is these are both
open source and anybody can use them we
look at sas and tabloo
those are two packages that are paid for
which have a lot of automation behind
them
so a lot of the larger companies will
pay for those packages because they help
work out a lot of the the back end stuff
before you even need to use them
and of course we have apache spark you
almost have to know apache spark in the
growing data
lakes today that's your big data how do
you distribute this if you're going to
process it over a large amount of data
we look at data science applications
there's
internet search very common you enter
your google thing and it uses the data
science
algorithms to figure out what to return
voice assistance
analyzing the voice coming in and
connecting it with
whatever patterns they need to activate
so you can ask it to turn your lights on
in the living room
healthcare biggest field growing right
now how do we analyze health data from a
smart watch
and figure out how to know when a
disease is being spread across the world
health care how do we identify cancer
versus non-cancer so we know who to
prioritize and get them in for surgery
where other people might not need that
immediate care and even identifying
problems somebody might have with their
health long before they even happen
what a neat thing to do instead of
waiting till you have a heart attack
to know months ahead of time that you're
having heart conditions
logistics how do we get from point a to
point b
if you ever look at some of the major
distributors they pre-ship things based
on what they guess people are going to
need
this way you get your stuff right in the
mailbox the day after you order it
e-commerce huge in there because you
have to know what kind of marketing
we're going to put out
who are we selling to what's our target
audience robotics
one of the funner ones when you're
coming up into the future is how do we
automate
the different tasks we have from
self-driving cars
to manufacturing lines to
maybe even a self-robotic chef in the
kitchen
so we talk about solving problems with
data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms
and these really are kind of an overview
of some of the terminology you'll want
to know in
data science so we talk about that how
much or how many we're talking about
regression
regression basically means a number if
you've ever seen
stock charts you see the guess at what
the next sales price is or buy price is
that's all on your regression side
is it a or b classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of
how is this organized clustering this is
where we take things that look alike and
put them together so that we can then
make predictions on it
how different is this just like you have
clustering you have the opposite
anomaly detection how do we find things
that don't fit in where the outliers
what are things we might need to look at
that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in
it learns from the new data as to what
the next action is going to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression
classification clustering anomaly
detection reinforced learning
a lot of times when you put your model
together you might have multiple parts
of this
we might look at the clustering of data
and then feed it into a classification
is this a bad loan to make it the bank
or is this a good loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of
setup is we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person
should be allowed to take a loan out and
you can see that all of these start
coming in
and then a lot of the models reinforced
learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run
reinforced learning now we're starting
to automate that so that as the data
comes in real time
the models start updating themselves
they start figuring out a way to solve
new problems
as they occur and of course in robotics
reinforced learning is one of the
biggest growing fields
algorithms used in data science linear
regression
regression when you're looking at both
of these uh
think numbers we're talking regression
models and so linear regression figures
out the best line through the data
maybe it's looking for a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data
on a continuum so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool
if you used to call it a hack now it's
becoming mainstream
to look at the back end what made the
decision so it's really easy to trace
back to
how you arrived at the decision decision
trees are kind of nice that way
nearest neighbors k nearest neighbors is
your clustering k means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them
and builds a hierarchy where the k-means
and the k-nearest neighbor
look for things that kind of connect
each other how close are they
in data format db scan
another form of clustering your data
principle component analysis
so we start breaking up and looking at
the different components in our data
coming in
these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more
these are kind of the mainline ones and
each one of these has many settings
which you can play with
to build a better model to predict your
data and where you want it to go
let's go ahead and take a hands-on demo
and just see what does this look like
now i'm going to go ahead and use the
anaconda navigator
and the which is your jupiter notebook
which will then open up in google chrome
this
is one of the ides or ways of editing
python code
i like this one because it one protects
my computer and creates its own kind of
container
and two it's got a really nice visual
demo for doing python
certainly you can use a number of other
different tools like pycharm
there's another real popular one you can
actually access pycharm code through the
anaconda navigator now
and there's a lot of other tools on
there that each have their benefit
and we come into our jupiter notebook go
and create a new python i've already
done that
and we'll start with a lot logistics
regression model just so you can see
what this looks like in code we'll
actually do two of these
as we go through this and take a look
and see what that code looks like in
python
now the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is
load up all our parts modules that we
need in our python code
i'll go and run that and you'll see here
i'm gonna ignore
warnings because some of the stuff we're
doing uh we're just looking at it
and as you go from one version of python
to one version of whatever
the site kit or in this case the sc
package
you'll see some warnings come up they're
not really important right now
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the german credit
data csv and so when i run this this is
all loaded up
now let's go ahead and just open up this
csv file so you can see what that looks
like
and here is here's our german credit
data file
we'll go ahead and just open that up
with let's do
wordpad just fine because it's a word
document
and when we open that up you can see
right here it's just a bunch of comma
separated values
we have across the top it actually has
columns on here so our first row is a
bunch of columns
and then of course we look down here
oops i just move stuff around but that's
okay i'm not going to save it
and you can see the values al1 al4
whatever that means or a14 i guess
and then some sort of numbers on here
and we'll take a closer look when we get
into
the program and looking at the data for
right now we've loaded that
under credit df
and at this point i want to just kind of
take a detour
back to the life cycle of data science
so we can see
how that fits in there and so
we've already done our data discovery we
have a little data prep but the data is
pretty clean
it already comes in preset on there
we'll make do a little data preparation
in here
we're going to start looking at
exploring the data analysis
and building a data model and then
interpreting the results
so really we're focusing on the last
three steps of this
the data discovery would be asking uh
start asking questions of what do we
want in there is this going to be
is this going to be a good loan a bad
loan what do we want to get out of this
data where are we going with it that
would be part of the data discovery
and a lot of times that might be a
meeting you have with the management in
the office or whatever
and then data preparation is of course
cleaning the data up
making sure you know where the source
came from
all those kind of fun things that go
into making sure you have good data
coming in
now you'll notice here we've got
we're using pandas whoops drew it
through the pandas
and we're going to go ahead and read it
as a pandas data frame
and of course pandas sits on numpy so a
lot of stuff you do with pandas can go
right into numpy very easily
and the reason i bring this up is
because pandas has a lot of tools in
there for just looking at the data real
quick and easy
and so the first one we want to go ahead
and do is do credit
dot df or credit underscore df our data
we read in
info and just see what that looks like
and when we go ahead and print this out
you can see here we have
13 columns remember we were looking at
our data and it had those that
row you couldn't read across the top
then it has
non-null count how many values don't
have null what kind of objects are they
they're an object an integer
different things like that and we look
at object is it a checking account
this is probably text on here duration
how long
credit history amount savings account
present employee employed sense so a lot
of different numbers coming in here and
these are just the columns we're looking
at
and if you're going to look at the
columns it's kind of nice to actually
look at the data
and so we'll use the pandas to go ahead
and print it out just like you would on
a spreadsheet
hard to see them all on here but you can
see we have here's our row across the
top because panda does
such a good job sorting out columns
and the actual data checking account a11
a12 a14 not sure what that means
duration how long they've had it credit
history
not sure what the a33 or a34 means
i'm sure it has a special meaning on
there the amount
here's our savings account and all the
information on that
and this is actually a very much more
easy to read view than what we had
before
as far as like that text file when
you're just looking at data through the
database sometimes those can be really
hard to read
this you can really see and if i take it
down a notch i can get all the columns
in here
we'll go ahead and keep it zoomed in
just so we can see that what's going on
a little easier
and then we can also do credit
df.ilocation
the ilocation feature in the pandas
is going to go ahead and do rows 0
through 5
and we're going to look at columns 1
through 7. and let's go ahead and just
run that
and you can see right here how we just
split it up so it's really easy to
manipulate our data and get a
smaller view of different parts of the
data as we're going through it
and just like we can look at the first
seven columns
we can also look at the last seven
columns
same kind of format we're looking at
rows 0 through 5
column 7 to the end if you leave the
number out there
and you can see we can easily now look
at this on a smaller screen
much better for displaying those are
just tricks to help you display
your information so that when you
present this in front of a
group of people it makes it very easy to
read
or you just copy this out and put it
into a document that kind of thing
and then we also like to go ahead and do
like
credit status value counts and things
like that
again we're just looking at the
different uh
sets of information on here and in
our pandas data frame value counts as
we're looking at
unique values so there's a lot of unique
values in here that's
700 and 300 that's a significantly
diverse set of data
and if we look at the data one of the
things we're looking at
is the status 0 1
0 0 1 and i'm going to guess that that
means that it is either default or not
default
so that's probably what we're going to
want to look for hopefully you've had
your
specialty and domain remember we talked
about the different parts of data
science
domain is what field it is in this would
be in banks and loans
and so if we want to figure out what the
status of a new loan is
we're going to separate the status out
and so if we take our
x features equals a list of the columns
that's all this is credit underscore
df.columns
we remove status and then we go ahead
and this will print our features out and
you can see it's everything but
the status on the end because that's
what we want to predict we want to
predict the new data
whether that status is 0 or 1 or not and
next we want to do a little bit more
data preparation we're going to go ahead
and encode
um and we're going to take an encode
credit df we're going to create that off
of
our setup on here
and you're going to ask well what are we
encoding on here well when we go up to
here
let me just go back all the way when
we're looking at all this information up
here
you can see there's uh object
object object well
if i'm doing a prediction and
something's just a random object it
doesn't really mean
anything there's no numbers to process
and so when we come down a little
further
we can see down here that we are looking
at
a65 i'm not sure what a65 means
we're looking at a93 personal status
we're looking at
a143 these aren't actual numbers there's
some kind of
code that the bank put in probably and
so
for our model they really don't mean
anything unless we convert them to
numbers
and you convert them to numbers by
literally creating
a bunch of yes no's so instead of
thinking it
as as a173
and a172 as being 0 1 and if you had an
a7 174 maybe 0 1
2 you would think of this as a label
a173 is true or false and then you'd
have another label
a172 as true or false so for every
unique
job in here that it becomes another
feature added in
and it's on or off it's true or false
that's what this
encoding is doing and we'll go ahead and
list our encoding as it comes out
and if you come up here you can see it
did exactly
what i was describing we've now encoded
it
so here's checking account a13 checking
account
a1214 a31
here's all of our uh checking account
numbers
so there was three of them uh here's our
credit history a31 a32 833
34. again the computer has no idea of
knowing what those are
all it knows is those are each unique
features and the same thing with the
savings account a62 and so on going down
and so once we have our nice list of
there we can go ahead and do
pull this in here we go let's look at
our new data set
and if we go ahead and run the new data
set we have our income credit df
uh checking and we're just going to look
at these and look at the head
this is just the first few of these so
we can see what it actually looks like
in the data
and just like i said it's now 0
0 0 0 one one zero zero
this first column is just the count zero
one two three four that's not
part of the data but you can see here
that it just puts a check mark of one uh
because it's an
ac a12 and we have a checking account ac
a14 where it's also a check mark of one
going across
so we've done a little data preparation
we've come in here and done some
exploratory data analysis and now we
want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model
and then interpreting the results on
this and so when we go ahead and import
our stats models as api
as sm now a lot of times we use the
sk learner the scikit models in this one
we're going to go ahead and use the sm
model
from stats models which is pretty common
for doing a very basic logistics
regression model
uh and then from the scikit we're going
to have our train test split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your day in your setting
up your models is to split it up into
your training set and your
testing set and what i want you to
notice on here is we have
x train well what is x train that's all
the columns
except for the last one which was the
status was it default
or was it in in good standing
and then of course our x test is part of
the data we're going to split that up
by 0.3 so 30 of the data is going to be
30 of our rows are going to be put in
the x test
and the y train and y test is just the
status
and then we create our once we've
created our data and split it up we go
and create our model
and it's a logit we're just going to
call it logit but you could a lot of
times you end up seeing logic model
with logit it equals the sm
logit x train
y train x train in sk learn it's always
x train y train
uh but in the um stats model it's
reversed on there
uh and then they go ahead and run the
fit so we load the data up and then we
fit it
and then we can go ahead and summarize
that model and see what it looks like
let's go ahead and run that it takes it
just a moment
and we get a nice summary of our data
again we're still
looking at the data and we have
takes just a moment to to kind of feed
through and you can certainly see
where we have our coefficient which has
to do with the weights
in the model standard error that's very
important as we look at this coefficient
and how it affects the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
z 0.025
these are all your statistical notes on
here
so as you look at these you might look
at like
how big is a standard error that's one
of the big ones that i usually look
at um as we go up and we start looking
at the different things
uh the higher the error the less uh the
more we want to be a little careful of
it the lower the error the better
in more general terms they also have
dealing with the model and it's
iterations you can see some general
status on here how many iterations that
i have to go through
before i was able to come up with the
numbers because it kind of guesses it's
playing a high-low game and it takes it
six iterations until it finds what it
considers the best fit
uh and you can see there's more
information up here as far as
when it converts how it converts and so
on now when we have
our summary up there one of the
questions starts coming in remember i
told you we're looking at like our
standard error
and you know how these numbers all are
telling us
how important each one of these features
is in running our prediction
and if you have a ton of features and
some of them
are just kind of all over the place all
they do is create noise
so we really want to get rid of them
they also cause issues in that if you're
running a huge amount of data and you
have to rerun this model over and over
again
this can really text your time and so
you're losing both time money and your
results might not be as good because
they might be weighted based on some of
these very fuzzy numbers
so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that
again we're we've come in if you
remember from
back here we're still in kind of an
exploratory data analysis
and data modeling they kind of go hand
in hand sometimes
we haven't quite got to interpreting the
results in running predictions and so
we'll go ahead and
build this thing on here it looks at the
lm values
so that's coming up here where this was
generated
i'd have to actually look that up for
the this particular
model because i usually use the sk
learned version of this
so as we look at this we're going to
look at the p values
of our variables and basically we're
looking to see how good the p
values are if they're less than or equal
to 0.05
we probably those are probably solid
values
and if they're greater than that then
probably we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we
pull out all the values that are less
than or equal to 0.05 for the p
values and if we go up here here we go
here's our p
i knew it was up here i just wasn't
seeing it correctly
so you can probably see duration that's
going to be good
amount 0.01 that looks good instance
instant
inst rate which i'm guessing is the
percentage rate or the
interest it's trying to say in inst and
interest at the same time
so we have our interest rate and all
that if we come down here we see
duration amount
our instant rate age checking account
a13
checking account a14 credit history a34
savings account
65. these are our primary features these
ones are related when we look at the
data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our sm model or our final logit
model
and you'll see here we now have the
x-tray the
y-train and then instead of the x-train
it's x-train
significant variables right there so all
we're doing is
is running this just on the significant
variables in the setup
and we'll go ahead and fit it and you
can see here you can actually um
double bracket and do it all in one line
up above we had to do it in the
two lines this is how the setup is for
this particular
module and then we'll go ahead and do a
final legit summary
and just see what that looks like and we
can see here here's our p scores
remember they're all supposed to be
under point o um
underneath the 0.05 these are all under
0.05
you can see up here different statuses
as far as how it ran it still took
six iterations to go through the data
the date and so forth and now that we
have a solid model
and that's if you remember correctly let
me flip back on over here we've done our
data modeling
we've created a solid model and so now
we need to actually run a prediction
so that we can interpret the results and
weigh in on that and see how good they
are
and so for that i'm going to go ahead
and
let's find it over here
why predict so we have our model that we
created
we want to go ahead and create our y
predict and it's based on our
final object and here's the magic word
predict
or dot predict and so this is where
we're going to come in and actually get
our predictions on here
that our model comes up and remember
we're testing um
x test is going in there's our x test
and it's only the significant variables
so we've created our model now we want
to push in our test version that's never
seen this data before
so this is all new and then we're just
going to take a random sample to see
what it looks like
what do those predictions look like in
this random sample we're just looking at
10 of these
and you can see here is the actual
number it says 0.08
gives us a 1 0.07
this is our probability number which is
i would have to actually look to see
whether higher or lower is better
i'm guessing the closer to
zero the better it is but i'm not
completely sure on that i have to
actually look up on
and see with this particular framework
uh but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero
so i guess this is a good loan a bunch
of defaults and some good loans that's
what it predicts it's going to come out
as
now just looking at the data you know
it's confusing this is you have
different models they have different
setup they have the
predicted probability comes out on this
and other models it doesn't
so you really need a tool to dig deeper
into
the setup to understand what this means
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take
our predicted values which you can see
right here has an actual
predicted probability and then we're
going to go ahead
and insert on there from a sample
let me just run this because it'll make
a lot more sense
we have our actual value and our
predicted value
so this is what we predicted and this is
the actual setup
if we just look at this right off the
bat we can see that we predicted zero
and this was a one
these all came out correct uh number 332
came out correct
917 was an actual they were good on
their loan they predicted it's going to
be a default
you start to see that there's some
variance so how do we measure that how
do we know whether our model was any
good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and load up
a nice graft and we'll use for our graph
we'll import matplot library pi plot
and seaborn seaborn sits on matplot
library
and this matplot library inline is just
because i'm using jupiter notebook with
the new version i'm in it doesn't even
need it
but i tend to leave it in for older
versions and then we rope
import from our sk learn metrics
this is your scikit scikit is the main
package and
sklearn is how it looks on here and
we'll go ahead and
run that so it's nicely loaded and then
we'll go ahead and create a little
routine
in just a moment here to print this out
so we can see
what that looks like and this metrics
it's kind of a fun matrix because it it
tells you
like how many you have correct on the
correct one
how many you had wrong on the wrong one
and this top part is just all
a draw routine so it comes in here and
has our actual and are predicted
and it's our cm metrics it breaks it up
puts it into the heat map the sn heat
map gives it
some colors add some labels
and then we go ahead and show it and
we're just going to dump that in there
and run that
and you can spend forever building
graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit uh
we have bad credit good credit we have
predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here if
it had on the good
credit it tells you how well it
predicted it and how many false
positive it has and on our bad credit
um here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
were bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
well 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be
bad credit and then we have here we have
188 that were good credit
uh but the actual val and then it had 61
there were bad credit that it said were
good were predicted
good credit uh so at this point you look
at this and you'd say well
if i'm predicting uh these
are this is our good credit here
let me flip this on over here and this
is our
bad credit there we go
so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking at and you say okay
can we afford that many defaults after
five years or whatever it is
and so those are the questions you start
asking is does this model work good
enough to predict whether we should give
these people loans or not
you're always going to have somebody
default on them and again that starts
going into domain
banking domain something i don't know
very much about
clearly i know whether i default that
alone or not which i don't and i try
very hard not to
and then if we're going to draw the
chart which is really nice to have just
a clear visual chart
metrics also has our classification
report
and you can see these are just the
numbers we were looking at
they let us know the precision
uh our f score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print a
straight up metrics classification
report
now we looked at a regression model
let's go ahead and look at a clustering
model to see what that looks like
and we'll go ahead and create a new
group
python on there and this is going to be
our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and switch on over to my clustering menu
in this case we're going to be looking
at k means clustering
so let's just put that up here okay
means clustering
now the last one was a regression model
so it figured out coefficients for lines
you can go back to your old euclidean
geometry
or the algebra expression for a slope on
a line y
equals mx plus b or whatever
and it goes on from there as far as
finding distances
and figuring out the lines on there this
is a little bit different
we talk about clustering it uses similar
ideas but it has to do with edges two
points and how do you figure out a
distance between two points and what
does that mean
now you'll see here we have our pandas
pd our numpy as np
our matplot library seaborn sits on
matplot libraries we talked about
um they've added some parameters here
as far as colors and then we did an
inline for the matplot library
again that's not really necessary even
in the new version
of the jupiter notebook in the old
version jupiter notebook if you didn't
do that it would just kind of hang or
disappear
and then we're going to import some data
it's important to have our
data set up in here and
instead of looking at this and
guessing what the data is
usually open up the csv file at this
time let's just go ahead and print it
under the df
head because really those those text
files are so messy and you look at the
df head and it's easy to look at
whoops had a path issue there so college
data
it's a csv so automatically knows
there's a dot csv on there
and we can see here that they downloaded
from a number of colleges
um abilene christian university adelphi
university
adrian college and then it has whether
it's private
i'm guessing yes or no apps i'm not sure
what that is
acceptance rate applications i'm betting
and then the acceptance rate
enrollment top ten percent top two
five percent undergrad so on so these
are just statistics based on
the college their college getting into a
college
and just like we did before let's
explore the data if you can remember
from the chart we were looking at
we're going through our data discovery
data preparation
and exploratory data analysis so we're
really kind of looking at the data and
what do we have here what came in
at this point the data has already been
prepared we are not doing a whole lot as
far as
getting rid of null values and finding
out whether it's bad data or good data
and that kind of thing
and data discovery would be figuring out
which data to send
so that we've already done so we're
going to do the exploratory data
jump into data modeling and interpret
the results just like we did with the
other one
and we'll go ahead and use the panda
tool to get the info
df you'll see df very commonly it just
stands for data frame a lot of people
use it as a generic setup when they
import from pandas
and so we have our info and you can see
right here uh
non-null numbers here's our count so
each one of these has 777 non-null
values
and again here's our type of data we're
dealing with
and if you remember from last time
here's an object
um this was our yes or no
everything else looks like it's integer
we do have a float value here
uh integer integer floats and integers
usually they're when you're running them
on a prediction they're pretty
interchangeable in a lot of cases
but whether it's private true or false
that's pretty important on here
the fact that they could probably be
switched to a zero or one
is pretty helpful also and if we're
going to look at all that data we can go
ahead and describe it
so there's our data frame describe
and you have the same thing here's our
count all these should be 777.
we have the mean value so you can
actually look at what our average is
standard deviation minimum different
quartiles 25 50 the third quartile that
so on
and of course our max value on there min
and max
and as we explore the data we can do a
lot of fun things on here
we're going to use our seaborn and we're
going to look at
a room and board versus graduation date
we're going to add this is going to be a
heat map so we're going to add
whether it's a private college or not um
how it fits the size the aspect ratio
and all that that's what this line is
here
seabourn you can almost do your own
class on matplot library in seabourn
because there's so many features in
there but when you look at the very
basics you can throw up some data
and have a nice colorful map set up
and here we have our graduation rate
compared to room and board costs and in
private
or public
so you can see that the graduation rate
uh compared to room and board hit
play interesting thought how much did i
spend on room and board
am i going to graduate the more i spend
on room and board and you can see
numbers go up there on graduation rate
and you can see that the
graduation rate tends to go way up for
your private schools
uh and the room and board also goes
continues to grow on private schools
kind of thing it's kind of just a fun
heat map
and we can explore other things in our
doing our heat maps
we can look at out state whether it's
out of state
undergrad private again is one of our
setups on here
and you can see here that for undergrad
there certainly is a lot more public
schools
and whether it's out of state
interestingly enough the out of state
number goes way up how many people
coming from out of state into the school
for the private schools
just kind of fun things if you're trying
to figure out where you're going to go
maybe you'd want to do this for picking
a bachelor's degree or a master's degree
or something or
certainly you could also plot this with
fun locations and download information
on tourism sites if you're traveling
that kind of thing you do the same kind
of thing with
and we'll go ahead and throw out another
map on here let me go and run this
this is a slightly different setup on
here with the outer state
and so we're running let's see pull this
up
bins 20 the bins is each how many
bins are you going to split it into and
this is kind of a fun one where you can
see
private versus public we have how many
out of state
and i'd have to look this up to see what
they picked on
oh here we go okay so you can see we
have another chart that has to do with
the outer state and the number of
students coming in
and private and public uh so
a lot of different setups on here as we
dig into the different
graphing so at this point we've just
been kind of looking at
the graphs on here let's go ahead and
import our cluster our k-means cluster
and you can see here we have we're going
to call it km i guess for k
means or maybe it's k means model
i always label mine with model equals k
means in clusters equals 2 random state
equals
90. uh and so
we're when we cluster it we're only
going to cluster into two groups
that's what this this is meaning here um
across the different settings on there
and then we're going to go ahead and fit
uh
and we're going to drop private so
we're not going to be looking at whether
it's a private or public school we're
just going to go ahead
and run the cluster on there
and then once we run the cluster on
there we can actually look at
cluster centers let's go ahead and do
that on this
we talk about k means let me run this
boom there we go
so we have
all these different columns and each of
those columns has a center
and we start looking how the data comes
together on those centers
that's what all these numbers this is
the hidden stuff behind the clusters on
here
and so we can now do maybe we'll create
a little converter here
if private equals yes return one else
returns zero
we're going to run our cluster private
and apply the converter
and then we'll go ahead and print that
out let me just show you what that looks
like so you can see what we're doing
here
and then we go ahead and do a df cluster
we'll create a new
column on here private apply converter
and we can see here it creates some
private apps except
we've just added on to our data frame on
here
and we did that so that we can run the
confusion matrix
make sure we import our confusion matrix
we're going to do a classification
report confusion matrix
and we'll go ahead and run this on our
clustering
and use you can see here as we're
predictions
uh here's our confusion matrix up here
just like we had on the other setup
where it has how many
um false true false false
true false and false false as your
accuracy
and are set up on there this is really
uh if you're looking at which
where you want to go maybe looking at
where you want to go in a
i think more of a tourism thing but um
for colleges this is a great way for
looking for a bachelors or a masters
coming in here and you can start finding
out which one you want to go to
based on this accuracy whether it's
private or public
or how many graduations are on there so
we looked at a couple examples went
through some of the parts
of the cycle whether using a k-means or
linear regression model
and certainly this cycle and these
models you start to see that there are
some similarities we're doing the same
thing and each model has
a better setup depending on what you're
trying to accomplish on there
i hope that you were able to get an
overview of some of the things you look
at in data science in our data science
tutorial
welcome to simply alert thank you for
joining us today for more information
please visit
www.simplylearn.com get certified
get ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here